[Music]
let's go to kate in fort myers what's up
kate
hello how are we doing
i'm doing well how are you we're
figuring it out
figuring it out what's up
um my
issue
is that my
i let things bother me that are outside
the realm of my influence
me too tell me what you're struggling
with
um well my father passed away 20 years
ago okay and ever since then my brother
has used this opportunity to
i financially exploit my mother
he has a lot of influence over her
how is he exploiting her
um
well just she just told me a story last
week where she had given him a check for
30
30
a blank check she gave it to him because
he needed um
to get a license for his dog
well he took that check and he wrote it
out for 600.
so he's stealing ten years ago yeah
about ten years ago
her house burned down
and she got
a hundred and twenty thousand dollars
from the insurance he slowly but surely
took money from her from that toward the
point where
there's no money left he kept saying
i'll go buy the wood and
repair the house i'll go buy this piece
of equipment and fix the house up out
you know and he just slowly but surely
drained all that money from her
so
what what part about that can you not
control or is she just allowing it
because if i'm you yeah i'd call the
cops i'd get an attorney i'd get i'd
i'd raise all kinds of
sideways barn fires to get in there on
that i don't
what part can you not control unless
you've talked to her and she says yeah
well that's just your brother
is that what's happening she
yeah she keeps saying well he's gonna
fix that house for me someday he owes me
that money and he's going to
take care of it and in her will
she has left
him
the only asset she has left which is her
120 acre farm
she's left that to him in the will
why not
why not me because i'm a boy
the boy gets the farm the boy gets the
farm and we've talked about it and she
even has said what's the girl get the
plates uh the girl gets the plates yes
the girl gets plates um
why
it's the i want to keep it in the in the
name the lab i won't say my last name um
yeah i want to keep it in the you know
and i don't have that same last name
whatever it's whatever i'm not i don't
want anything from her yeah i don't want
anything i've told her
you know use your money on you
spend it on you
you know
so when this thing when this thing goes
sideways
when ultimately your brother has
completely
poked enough holes in the bottom of this
um
fish tank for there to be no more water
left there's no more money
all right are you going to be
responsible for taking care of mom
is she going to move in no
no my other my other sister will i mean
i will if my other sister
there's three girls and one boy in the
family okay all of us girls you know try
to help her try to and it's
i let go of it about 10 years ago but
recently she started helping out another
person who's taking advantage of her her
nephew
who's moved in with her and is taking
advantage and that's what got kind of
brought it up again yep
and i just i want to be able to
have a relationship with her
but it's so hard when she won't set any
boundaries i feel like i have really
good healthy boundaries i set with
people and i want to cut her out of my
life
i want to be there for her
but then she'll just drop this you know
a story like she just told me the other
day she drops the story on me
oh i gave him a check and he
wrote it up for 600 well i closed that
account so it's all okay now and i'm
like but it's not okay yeah it's just
it's the sun
robbing his mother i i mean
in the
of course any kind of being a thief is
being a thief right um
and not telling the truth it's not
telling the truth and blah blah blah but
stealing from your mother man
you know what i mean like that's yeah
that's next level
yeah um he even he even
maybe it was 15 years ago right after my
dad passed away
he threatened suicide
you know so because
you know owen was going to help me out
kind of thing so i think she's always
got that in the back of her head
that if she doesn't help him out and the
worst part of that well not that that's
not bad enough but the worst part of it
is
her mother committed suicide oh yikes
she knows the pain of that and it's like
if that's his undue influence over her
for the last 15 years is you know i
think he just kind of drops that little
sounds like your mom's had a lot of big
hurt in her life
and
she has developed some pretty
miraculous slash pathological ways of
segmenting people's behaviors so that
she can keep people in her life
and um
unfortunately the good kids
the three daughters who are
still coming around and still trying to
be supportive
y'all bear the emotional weight that she
can't carry
because she just fluffs it off right
so
two important things here one is
mom is a proxy right now you haven't
made peace with your brother
so you either need to have your
conversation with your brother
and let everything be said that you want
to be said
um
write him a letter and say all the
things that you are stealing from our
mother you should be ashamed of yourself
i know she raised you better than like
you need to have that conversation with
him all three of your sisters need to
have that conversation with him whatever
um or
in some families that can happen other
families that can't so i won't speak
into which one and you are you you know
your sisters and your brother
my guess is just talking to you for a
few minutes if that conversation would
have been fruitful you'd have had that
years ago and so my guess is that's not
a fruitful conversation
if it's not
you have to make peace with the haunting
fact that part of what made your brother
made you
and when our brothers and sisters do
things that hurt other people by
extension we're like that's kind of can
i do that right it's kind of it's this
ext you're gonna have to
cut that tie
you're gonna have to put up a really
firm boundary i don't talk about my
brother i don't acknowledge this guy
he is a crook and he steals from my
mother
and so the only way i can preserve my
dignity and my treating other people
with respect
is to say that person does not exist i i
am a person who always leaves um an
unlocked door for somebody to return
but that person that's them i can't
continue to chase you down right
and my gut tells me is when you make
peace with that whatever your choice is
there
then the conversation with your mom when
she starts telling about the nephew
saying mom you know i don't think he
should be living here
i think he's stealing from you and i
will not have a conversation about him
let's talk about something else
okay right and so that's you you're not
taking control of your feelings what
you're doing is you're taking control of
the on and off ramp you're putting a
toll stop there
so that when that thing gets when the
car tries to drive through you're
stopping it before it even gets going
right see what i'm saying that that is
the only way i've found to stop stuff
when i'm
worrying about things i can't control i
can't stop worrying about russia and
ukraine so i have to cut off my access
to the information about it on a 24 7
see what i see 365
i'm doing
do you talk to your sisters about this
yes
all the time and my they both live very
close to her i'm
1200 miles away
so i get you know
i get the stories from my mom i you know
but i also get them from
my sisters and then that's all we end up
talking about for
you know 20 minutes
what he's doing yeah i think i mean
that's the further extension of the
boundaries just talking to your sister
either somebody either there's an
intervention and the three daughters go
sit with mom and say we want this crook
out of your house
um and then she might say well forget
you guys i want you all out of my house
and that's one of those relational risks
that you got to take when you're trying
to save somebody
um
i don't know enough to know whether
she's
desperate for someone to come in and
save her
or if she doesn't give you all that
power my guess is if y'all had that
power you would have used it by now but
the worst part about boundaries with
family is
boundaries come with a risk and the risk
is they could say no
buy and walk away and that's gut
wrenching and
i'm telling you you're trying to
preserve a relationship with your mother
which is noble and good but you also
can't see her you can't stand by and
watch where she allows herself to be
held under water by a criminal son and a
criminal nephew
and so it may be that the best way to
protect yourself is to extricate
yourself from the situation turn your
like say i'm not having these
conversations anymore um
i don't think it's beyond getting with
your two sisters and calling an attorney
and seeing if she's got the ability to
care for herself with the way they're
draining her
or whether it's worth getting the
authorities involved or at least having
an attorney write your brother and write
your nephew a letter that says if
another dollar comes out right your mom
may say no i can do what i want to with
my money and that's just heartbreaking
and that's
adults can do what adults can do
um but it may be worth throwing a
grenade to see what happens that's
probably what i would do just because i
i don't know i don't i have a hard time
taking no for an answer sometimes but
just hear me say this i'm sorry this is
hard hard hard